[Applaudissements]
qui était fausse tout au moins erroné au
final deuxième raison officielle qu'on
invoquait c'était les liens présumés
entre le régime de Saddam Hussein en
Irak et le groupe acadège demain qui
était à l'origine du 11 septembre ça
aussi ça c'est avéré pour le moins
trompeur au-delà de ça il y a le lien et
ça monsieur chrétien aussi à faire
référence qui était non avoué assez
évident pour quiconque l'historique de
la région il y avait l'aspect
géostratégique et plus spécifiquement
énergétique ça je crois que c'est c'est
gros c'est très grossièrement connu mais
l'origine même de les rats dans tous les
détails là je pense que c'est très
méconnu du public c'est un pays
essentiellement un gouvernement qui a
été créé largement toute pièce par
l'Empire britannique pourquoi parce
qu'on voulait avoir un régime
sympathique avec lequel c'était facile
de transiger au niveau du pétrole donc
il y avait cette dimension là très
certainement et la raison la plus
peut-être fondamentale d'un point de vue
philosophique qui à la base était peu
évoqué mais au fil du temps qu'on a
commencé de plus vous aura plu à
mentionner un public lorsqu'on ne
trouvait pas les armes de destruction
massive une fois qu'on a commencé à
démontrer qu'il y avait pas vraiment de
lien de Saddam et Al-Qaïda c'était la
question encore une fois philosophique
de la démocratisation du Moyen-Orient et
de façon plus large de la planète ce que
le président d'embauche et c'est propre
conseiller disait et se disait et ça
c'est en passant c'était vrai avant
septembre c'était que la meilleure façon
la seule façon peut-être même d'assurer
la sécurité des États-Unis de sécurité
en fait la sécurité de l'Occident de
façon plus générale c'était d'enrayer la
tyrannie à la grandeur de la planète et
on a eu un renversement de régime ou une
tentative de renversement tyrannique de
régime céramique après l'autre incluant
celui évidemment de Saddam Hussein en
Irak en 2003 dans une mouvance beaucoup
plus large qui était épousé par
l'administration bouche mais également
encore une fois par le gouvernement
britannique de Tony Blair qui était de
dire mais justement des dictatures de la
sorte c'est une menace intrinsèque à
notre mode de vie on doit les faire
sauter et par la force
si on voit le besoin ce qui en énorme
partie explique ce qu'on a vu comme
décision est maintenant 20 ans il faut
dire que c'est quelque chose à l'époque
dire non parce que le Canada c'était
l'allié indéfectible des États-Unis à
l'époque il y avait des risques en
parler il y avait des risques pour le
Canada pour le Canada il y avait des
risques pour la bonne partie j'ai pas la
grande majorité mais une bonne partie
des alliés traditionnels et également
indéfectible des États-Unis oui Canada
mais également la France également
l'Allemagne et vous savez quoi il y a un
pays dont on parle très très peu dans le
contexte de Léa mais je crois qu'il est
drôlement pertinent et c'est la Russie
la Russie devl Vladimir Poutine qui en
privé pendant des semaines et des mois
tentaient de convaincre l'administration
bouche de ne pas envahir l'Irak monsieur
Poutine n'allait pas qui essayait de
part et d'autre là avec l'accident
d'établir des bases de collabor de
collaboration avait dit essentiments
présidente on vous a aidé avec votre
invasion de l'Afghanistan on veut
collaborer avec vous pour ce qui est de
la lutte au terrorisme de façon générale
mais dans ce cas-ci ne faites pas ça et
Monsieur
c'est comporter de la même façon avec
Monsieur Poutine qu'avec à peu près tous
les dirigeants étrangers incluents
monsieur chrétien incluent monsieur
Shroder c'est à dire il les a carrément
ignoré on fait comme s'il n'existait pas
à passer sur le corps de ce qu'on peut
appeler la communauté internationale
incluant encore une fois plusieurs des
alliés ou des partenaires stratégiques
des Américains et les impacts que ça a
eu Julie les impacts 20 ans plus tard on
les voit encore dans les a vu dans les
années 2010 avec la naissance de daech
avec le chaos généralisé dans le
Moyen-Orient et encore une fois je vais
ramené ça la Russie dans le cas
spécifique de Vladimir Poutine c'est ça
des implications qu'on voit encore à ce
jour parce que ça envoyait deux messages
très clairs le premier c'était
essentiellement confirmer la crainte
qu'il avait de dire si les Américains
aiment pas un régime quasi digitatorial
ou tout au moins qu'il ne le ressemble
pas qui ressemble pas au modèle
occidental il y a rien qui va les
empêcher d'intervenir et de faire sauter
ce que j'aime là donc qu'est-ce qui me
dit que tôt ou tard il ne viendront pas
il ne viendront pas pour moi et voyager
ça c'est une chose la deuxième en
concept dans le contexte de l'invasion
de l'Ukraine ça fait un acte monsieur
Poutine le répète qui sont les
Américains pour me blâmer ou m'accuser
d'avoir envahi un pays souverain alors
qu'ils l'ont fait eux-mêmes donc au
niveau de la cause du Conseil de
sécurité exact donc la perte de
l'aspect moralité l'autorité morale et
pas dans un encore dans un Vasco je dis
dans le contexte du 11 septembre mais
quelque chose de profondément tragique
là-dedans parce qu'au lendemain du 11
septembre c'était presque le monde
entier qui était derrière les États-Unis
c'est non seulement des pays comme la
Russie même écouter ça s'invente pas
même la Corée du Nord avait émis des
condoléances officielles envers les
États-Unis donc on avait le monde
derrière nous et on a sacrifié toute
cette bonne volonté là ce capital de
sympathie là avec une décision
essentiellement une latérale et j'ajoute
aussi également monsieur Bush le savait
c'est à dire que et ça a été documenté
dans un des ouvrages de Babou wood World
dans les années 2000 au lendemain du 11
septembre alors que clairement on
dessinait déjà avoir une tonne des plans
d'invasion de l'Irak monsieur bus avait
déjà en privé à ses conseillé écoutez
c'est très possible que dans un an ou
dans deux ans il y a seulement les
Britanniques qui sont encore avec nous
et malgré tout on a foncé directement
dans le mur impact politique à l'interne
aux États-Unis vous avez parlé de
l'image des États-Unis à l'international
qui a changé à ce moment-là mais à
l'interne aussi on a vu cette montée de
méfiance de la population parce qu'avec
le temps on s'est mis à dire notre
gouvernement peut nous mentir la preuve
ne sont pas des preuves et ça c'est un
argument qui a servi à Donald Trump
aussi dans les dernières années
absolument tout tout l'aspect
anti-establement de façon très larges de
façon plus spécifique leur sélection de
politique étrangères cette montée en
flèche de l'isolationnisme du
nationalisme aux États-Unis et incluant
peut-être particulièrement de façon
iranique au sein du parti républicain
dans les années 2000 les républicains
étaient le parti de l'interventionnisme
à l'international d'agir pour essayer de
régler des problèmes à droite et à
gauche dans le monde des fois de façon
militaire lorsqu'on le jugeait
nécessaire et ensuite à cette réaction
extrêmement vive justement au à la
catastrophe que c'est avéré cette
invasion là il y a eu cette montée là
personnifie également par Donald Trump
et de façon beaucoup plus large
effectivement ce Brie confiance qu'on a
combiné on se parle des années 2000
également à la crise financière de 2008
donc vous aviez deux événements extrêmes
moins chers ou une énorme partie de la
population américaine c'est dit écoutez
est-ce qu'on peut vraiment avoir
confiance en nos institutions on s'est
fait dire n'importe quoi les résultats
sont épouvantables donc l'héritage il
est d'une toxicité je crois qu'on peine
à vraiment pouvoir pleinement mesurer et
on a envie encore les conséquences c'est
ça qui est formidable d'une certaine
façon mais un maudit de façon très
générée que ici là c'est pas parce que
c'est triste à la limite de voir
justement ces conséquences qui perdurent
à quel point ça vient teinter les
regards à quel point ça ça joue contre
la démocratie finalement ça rejoint le
dossier de la guerre en Ukraine vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs si on regarde un
peu ce qui s'est passé cette semaine
attention encore montée entre la Russie
et les États-Unis alors là c'est cette
affaire de américaine je le rappelle
pour noter les spectateurs là qui
volaient au-dessus de la mer Noire qui a
été abattu par des avions russes et le
ton encore monté là il y a un sénateur
républicain monsieur
de façon virulente en disant si il
s'approche encore de nous on va à Bac
tous les avions russes en fait on
rajoute encore de la tension deux points
là-dessus Julie le premier c'est dans
quelle spécifique du drone il faut quand
même assigner la responsabilité première
où elle revient c'est à dire dans ce
cas-ci au pire c'est au gouvernement
russe qui depuis l'incident à peu près
tout fait pour minimiser et dire écoutez
on n'a pas utilisé d'armes on n'a rien
fait de mal alors que clairement il y
avait quelque chose de profondément
téméraire irresponsable et franchement
qui manquait du jugement de la part du
pilotrus de toute façon très objective
c'est la moindre des choses je crois
qu'on doit réaliser et reconnaître une
fois que ça s'est dit le deuxième point
et c'est là que le lien avec la guerre
en Irak et à quelque chose encore une
fois absolument fascinant et de
troublant pour certains peut-être même
de dégoûtant quelqu'un comme le sénateur
vous l'avez mentionné de nom pardon
Linke était à l'époque il y a 20 ans un
membre ce qu'on gagne américain qui a
voté pour la guerre en Irak on a encore
à ce jour des gens à Washington qui ont
endossé qui ont appuyé cette débarque
totalement et qui sont qui semble être
complètement capable incapable de la
moindre introspection et qui dès qu'il
survient encore à ce jour la moins de
tension internationale sont les premiers
à broyer pour qu'on en fasse davantage
pour qu'on monte au barricades il serait
peut-être sage ou se mettrait ceci Julie
dans 20 ans plus tard qu'on prenne un
pas de recul et du côté américain et
consomment justement l'interventionnisme
et le réflexe d'aller aux armes regardez
ce que ça a fait il y a 20 ans on a
envie encore les conséquences 20 ans
plus tard
analyse fort intéressante Raphaël Jacob
merci beaucoup pour votre regard et se
plongeon dans l'histoire et de ramener
ça sur les conséquences au présent
aujourd'hui merci infiniment je vous
laisse rapidement sur vous parler
d'histoire Julie il nous reste quelques
secondes ensemble jamais ce que je
croyais suivre une entrevue avec avec
Jean-Chrétien et je le mentionne
justement pour la petite histoire une
chose qu'on a en commun lui et moi c'est
peut-être la seule chose tous les deux
finissant du séminaire de Trois-Rivières
lui un petit peu avant moi je le
mentionne au passage comme ça c'est
vraiment une entrevue fascinante et je
vous félicite d'ailleurs sur cet passant
c'était génial pour ceux et celles qui
l'ont vu c'est très gentil je l'apprécie
merci beaucoup pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI
[Musique]